[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where steve
hooked me up what are we we are very
careful
stay careful baby stay careful baby and
we got ryan here it's me ryan i'm here
right he's the most careful you know why
we stay careful we need to protect this
and we need to protect jobs for ryan's
right jobs for ryan ryan likes money
right that's like money brian is good
with money too and then he just goes and
buys hella expensive guns yeah no no
cameras hey this guy is so thrifty
though
you're very thrifty because he he's like
yo hey check it out we got some new
[ __ ] drops there's some new discounts
on this website and you you is it
bothering you no i just wanted you to be
good on camera oh thank you thank you
thank you
it's like your dad just like hey come
here
a little bit would you give him a
[ __ ] clorox swiper
no you know i always eat and i have food
all over my face all the time yeah i
thought you gave him a [ __ ] bleach
wipe i started wiping my boy
you know what you're not the only guy
friend that does that for me like
multiple guy friends [ __ ] because i
always have food on my face are a lot of
them dads
is it like a dad instinct i have to do
that for my wife all the [ __ ] time
she eats the same way he does like all
of her monsters
am i right but i tell her to go clean
that [ __ ] up
tell them the wait first turn on the
damn timer [ __ ] me he's so bad at this
dude that's crazy this is why this is
why i just sit there and shoot threes
the whole time i'm not even looking all
right so we got this new thing guys on
on careful boys where
um you guys can ask us questions we used
to do this back in the day back back in
the day on facebook where people would
ask us questions and we would talk about
it here
but now
we got some questions for you and then
sometimes we will sporadically talk
about it on our instagram so make sure
you guys follow all of us so i asked a
fun little question and this one was the
most cool answer yeah and you know us
careful boys we're all about being cute
and safe so cute answers k-a-y-o-o-k-u
there it is we got a question from todd
loom i think he's been to me jesus
christ this is [ __ ] cute
how has bart and joe kept their
relationships strong over time oh track
all track that's all [ __ ] that's so
boost we're at jk guys you guys can't
see because you guys are obviously the
cameras are all set up but joe and bart
they're constantly looking at each other
in the eyes
they're constantly licking lips
they're constantly just making eye
contact we can't even we're not even
we're barely in the room you guys are
just staring at me
how long is our friendship because okay
this i think jk's 15th year
what or 14th or 15th jesus 2007. do the
math 15 next year that's actually pretty
crazy guys that's actually nuts yeah
that's crazy i can't believe we survived
on youtube for this long please but
we've known each other since like 2004.
oh [ __ ] that's super durable another
round of applause how many years is that
that's a whole ass high schooler right
there don't they say it oh
high
you're about to be an adult friendship
yeah do you guys have anniversaries with
each other no the reality is our
relationship is super strange we're not
friends we just do it for the camera
we're true influencers you know what i
mean like we do it for the views and
[ __ ] well real talk though like uh i
believe they say something like most
friendships only last where connections
and relationships only last like seven
years or something like that yeah right
and like people oftentimes recycle their
social media is that also associated
with because you know they say you get
brand new cells every seven years so
maybe you're a brand new person every
seven years so that's why it's a seven
year people do change though like just
seven years is a good enough time to
like kind of go into another phase of
life right like that yeah i mean people
cycle through jobs like we did we've
been bart and joe two times yeah oh [ __ ]
seven and then seven you guys really
like each other man
i think um well at least for me the
experience has shifted from friendship
to like family so it's like family no
it's like it's like that means you love
him but you don't always like him you
got to say that who's paul walker and
who's [ __ ] vin diesel i mean look at
him yeah it's like it's it's
i think it's like that level of comfort
where it's
it's it doesn't feel like there's this
weird you're a different person anymore
you know what i mean like like you're
you're like i'm coming into your house
it's more like
it's barton geo's house but it's our
it's our house
so no because because i was on this i
was thinking about this like i did this
whole ass road trip with hannah right
and then like one of our stops was like
sleeping over barts and stuff so we were
there and you were looking at hannah
you're looking at a bar and you're like
i rather sleep with bart
i'm used to cuddling with him and
hannah's like so would i
everybody would rather sleep with bart
you know
but um we stayed in one of his most
comfortable ass [ __ ] rooms right one
of his
one of his many most comfortable
[ __ ]
is it how many rooms five five
there's way more dude there's way more
yeah but i had a super
great sleep experience and when we woke
up um hannah was like it's probably
because you're in this space where
you're with like family and people that
you're familiar with and then it's a
cozy place it wasn't the mansion because
we were on the road non-stop that's why
and i wasn't getting good sleep you know
and i was like damn that's true and
after that we we went to hop around do
some other stuff and i'm like i can't
sleep again so you drove back to this
i was at another family member's house
but i was like you didn't sleep very
well there
an actual family you go to real blood
and you're like i'm uncomfortable
this way
i didn't have a bed there that's why so
i so was the man
[ __ ] the mansion had the bed right no
there's actually another i have a family
that remember that lives in vegas but
there was no bed in the extra room and i
came late so then i was like oh [ __ ] i
don't want there's no bed storage right
automatic blinds you have in your house
that's what makes it the ones that come
out uneven right
hey man i can understand you know the
comfort there's like that once you cross
a certain threshold where you've been
through enough [ __ ] with somebody just
like any relationship guy girl whatever
you know what i mean it's like there's
just that like
threshold of comfort where you're like
yo i'm not trying to [ __ ] around making
any new friends at this old age
and try to invest so much to get that
comfortable where i know exactly what we
get every single time i stay making
hella friends i don't think bart would
but i do but i know that you know he's
one of the few
well dude
yeah you guys tell us stories like bart
will be standing in his window and then
he looks out in his backyard in the
morning and joe's in his [ __ ] pool
and he didn't even know that joe was
over oh yeah wait is that a real story
yeah where weren't you were you training
with don at the time or i forgot what
happened oh yeah that's true but i was
like i was like okay come over and use
the pool whatever and then i
and i scheduled a training session so
they went through the side door and i
went outside and i was like oh babe
joe's in the back swimming
that's hilarious
yeah yeah so what would you guys say
just for a curiosity was like maybe like
the hardest moment in your guys
relationship i don't know if we've ever
had one no
you know what i think i do see joy like
family though i got i got lucky because
it's hard to find the combo of
friendship but also being able to do
business with someone
and because of uh this was my first
experience
i didn't know how hard it was until i
tried working with other people and i
saw like my own friends getting getting
into business with their friends and
stuff and i was like oh [ __ ] so
this is actually like not normal yeah
what drives you [ __ ] nuts about each
other yeah that's a real question dude i
think it's gotten to the point where i
accept
his flaws
but i laughed explicitly
so okay so but if you had to rank them
but if i had to if we were gonna go
there because we're gonna that is family
though that's family that's the most
family thing i've ever heard my aunt's
the one that farts and laughs at the
same time like that's dude your mom you
wrote
this guy
i think we all know i think we all know
this about bart is that when he has a
goal
no matter what his persistence
sometimes
it could be great like hey let's let's
let's do something for like a business
or whatever right you want that guy on
your team
but when you don't want to [ __ ] do
something he'll badger you until you
break and he will keep doing it for
years like trying to get all of us to
move to vegas
it's kind of working the thing the thing
is the funny thing is so like me and
joe's first like homie circle that's
also like their
complaint too
but i don't even know that i'm doing it
but then one time they're explaining it
to me they're like this is how it is
bart there's times where you're like yo
you wanna let's go out and eat dinner i
already told you
i've ate dinner i'm full yeah and then
30 minutes later i don't know how but
we're both at denny's together again
and i'm like i'm so sorry i don't even
know how
come on let's half of my food be cooked
in the fridge and i'm at [ __ ] at a
cafe with this dude today's video is
brought to you by curology
guys
if you're out there
and if you're like me
well don't be like my former self all
right i used to shampoo my hair and i
would grab that shampoo and put it on my
face and i will use that as my face wash
because i said soap is soap
but there's new technology now
and just like how you don't write emails
with a typewriter there's new ways of
taking care of your face especially if
you want to be presentable or if you got
acne or dark spots there's a lot of new
ways to help you take care of all that
especially in a custom way where you
don't have to go to the store and figure
out yourself that's right because that's
one of the things that made me go i
don't want to wash my face yeah because
i will go to the store and i will see
all these options
this and that i don't know what's going
on yeah and you want to end up looking
like michael jackson i know i don't want
to burn my face with all these chemicals
yeah so i said forget it bro i'm just
gonna do it the old-school way i'm gonna
get dirt and water and rub my face with
it because that's basically clay
but it didn't work okay yeah but
thank goodness curology hooked up with
me and they're like yo i'm gonna help
you we have a licensed dermatology
provider that can walk you through this
process all right you just it's really
easy you go on fill out a survey takes
like five minutes super simple and you
just tell us what your goals are and i
was like all right well i'm becoming
pretty damn old i want some anti-aging i
want some maybe like less wrinkles okay
i'm like greasy here but dry there hook
me up so they gave me a personalized
cream that i'm gonna be using you know
after i wash my face because in my
special kit i got a face wash that i use
in the shower so i don't have to use
shampoo for my face anymore and then
after that i dab it with my cream i have
a cool little routine and you know la is
a dry place so they also gave me some
moisturizer so when i'm not in hawaii
and this stuff is getting all ashy and
dry
it's nice and moist again yeah they got
all kinds of products like they got face
wash moisturizers and also body wash for
your whole body to take care of all of
your skin so if you want to take care of
your skin make sure you go to
curology.com off the record to get a
free 30-day trial to see if you like it
no strings attached you just got to pay
for shipping and handling but it is a
free 30-day trial and a lot going to
happen to your body and your face in 30
days makes you go to curology.com that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com slash off the
record okay bart what driving us about
this [ __ ]
the one thing that drives me nuts
but i also think is what makes joe's
genius is that he's impossible to
wrangle
because he's just crazier he's too
wiggly
action
i gotta take a [ __ ]
just leave before we started filming he
was like you guys want to go for a walk
yeah but i think his unpredictability
and his craziness is also what brings
his genius to whatever stuff that he
does so i just accepted that
joe is crazy and then so like uh like
when when he was gonna come over
uh jill was like okay cool like when
should i get the
the sheets like done so that the bed's
clean
i was like honestly
you can't predict anything it could be
10 a.m it could be 10 p.m it could be oh
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] gambling at the
encore i'm not coming over for two days
it could be literally anything just do
what makes it convenient for you
because if you're like a stickler to
what the schedule is going to be i'm
like it's going to be [ __ ] dude you
could say the term to everyone in this
room
it's joe and then they they already know
what that means even though the subject
could be whatever the [ __ ] it is they
have their own beating in their own head
it's like but it fills in the blank and
we're all like yeah that's true okay
yeah yeah my favorite is that one time
we're talking about joe's like wait does
everybody think i'm wild
just shirtless [ __ ] black feet on the
table with the weapon in his hand like
what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's joe's essence right there dude
and it's funny how that works because
he's like the most scheduled to the
minute two seconds too scheduled and i'm
like the opposite of that like i like a
rough schedule so i have an idea but
that that that schedule can be destroyed
and bombed upon if i don't feel like it
he schedules sex dude with his wife
she sits here with cold eyes and she
tells she's like he's [ __ ] puts it on
a schedule you guys have a google
calendar
he invites her to it yeah yeah she has a
book that time like a couple weeks in
advance for that's gonna happen yeah to
be honest i actually uh over this past
weekend uh after like i told you guys
when i was gonna sleep at this house
with nina but then uh we ended up
getting caught up at this concert so uh
he was like just be at my spot at 9 45
in the morning right obviously we're
[ __ ] i was drunk i was hungover wake
up in the morning and i'm like hurrying
nina out of the hotel i'm like we gotta
[ __ ] get to bars she said by 9 45
she's like yo okay bo no you don't
understand this guy's [ __ ] like
military time guy he's like be there at
9 45. he's sitting there 9 30 waiting
for you
like it's [ __ ] scary and he's the
only one he's there with a cup of coffee
like man why are you late dude he's like
i gotta show up he's coming out he's
like fully dressed like he's taking an
interview he's got his vlog camera ready
to go with the same [ __ ]
tissue in his didn't have a
yeah do blade
schedule those two or whatever
unpredictable dude he's very in tune
with his body if you guys could have had
like a snapshot of how me and joe used
to work together because he's like so
he's like super out there i'm super like
this is what i have to do with my
schedule when we first started jk on the
the original like property or like house
we lived on it was like a like a triplex
so he lived in the back and i lived in
the middle and since i want to schedule
a bunch a bunch of things i was like i
need a schedule and he goes i can't have
a schedule
because i need to write like whenever
i'm inspired right
and then so uh what we ended up like i
guess um our compromise was like okay
what are the overlap times
that we're awake because he back then he
would sleep out i was on the bobby lee
schedule dude yeah and then wake up at
like [ __ ] 3 p.m or whatever right and
i've always been like sleep by 10. i
just my body just shuts down so we end
up having like the schedule where like
we meet i think from like 11 a.m to
three because that was the hour's at
that was like uh where it overlapped and
so you would see
him come out in the back he brings out
this foldable table
and then you you see him like make like
his espresso you have this whole thing
like his [ __ ] hook
[Laughter]
on a pull out table like he would i
would just
i can hear the folding table being
dragged behind him as he walks by the
way
so like we both had like a hookah in
here we both had a quarter where he
would like write one or two sketches a
week i write one or two sketches and we
would like you know like do a read and
figure it all out and i'm there like
writing
i guess somehow writing comedy in like
the most military way
and i look out with like the blinds
how's he doing
[ __ ] smoking as hookah going crazy
and feels inspired and i would just hear
random piano keys playing now
i don't know but somehow like the
madness worked somehow which is crazy
one of the funniest things about being
on the show for many years
is that you guys are so comfortable with
each other and you guys go back so far
that you'll just we'll just be doing an
article or we'll be doing like whatever
we're doing right now and you guys will
mention like remember brian like back
you know oh yeah that was crazy and then
you guys were just talking about this
guy that nobody else knows who the [ __ ]
you're talking about
and we're like who the [ __ ] are you
talking about and then everyone at home
they're probably like sitting there
eating their food like who the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is the [ __ ] is this guy i still
watch to the end of it
[ __ ] just
help me help you
we have so much history though it's like
three years of no youtube just regular
friendship and then all the youtube and
then all the personal life stuff yeah of
course no but that's but that's so the
comfortability is so there that you
could just bring that up and then you
like talk to each other and then you
guys are like literally just
conversating with each other like you've
always said jk's like conversations in
the parking lot and you guys are really
doing that but then sometimes it's like
hey what the [ __ ] going on though
what the [ __ ] is going on
steve how long have you known these guys
oh man i mean it feels like it's been
forever but but we clicked like
immediately
as soon as he came in here we're like oh
[ __ ] dude that this guy's cool yeah as
soon as i saw you at tim's roast like
this guys
sent some more sensibility yeah i was
very blown away when i came here because
i really i actually even i got busted a
little bit because i really didn't know
jk at all and i don't like to i'm i'm a
strong cold improviser i don't like to
know what's going on before i go into
something so that i can not have
expectations i can just be comfortable
and just walk in and just like learn it
all as i go and like the first video i'm
in
uh i don't even know bart's name
and then
and then yeah i totally get but i
totally get busted by geo she's like you
don't know his [ __ ] name and i'm like
no no no i didn't know of course
but i really had no [ __ ] idea what
you're doing
cause you're walking into a room you
don't remember everyone's name in me
yeah it's a lot of people are
remembering they all look slandy-eyed to
you huh yeah yeah oh they all look
identical
that was the hardest part they're all
barking
did you call did you call him joe
yeah
i don't remember but i might have i i
don't it was i remember because i heard
of joe malia
i thought his name was joe malia yeah
that was it last name malia i had heard
of joe malia before because i was a
maker and i don't know like tim was
around and like so i had heard of you
you heard of joe molly at what maker
studios well i was in maker yeah these
guys are making a cult over there or
some [ __ ] but i never heard a jk when i
was over there it wasn't they didn't
call it jk they they said jomalia a
bunch so i i just remember hearing about
joe malia he's talking about joe ballier
dude yeah i don't know and so and i had
i think i'd seen your picture before too
and you you were a [ __ ] mean looking
dude back then too like you remember
your some of your pictures oh the ball
headed yeah the bald headed one that's
when i was just trying
that is the whole like different
lifetime too when me and bart were
friends during that time growing up and
then transitioning into youtube that was
a different freaking era because i think
youtube actually got me to cure my ptsd
gotcha yeah from this neighborhood i
expected you to be a completely
different dude than when i came in the
room and then i was like oh he's like so
he enjoys to eat because we're so used
to like the 90s late 2000s like sgv like
gang error of the sgv me and joyce to
eat and when people first started
recognizing us but hey you see that for
looking at us i'm like oh [ __ ] all right
we just think something's gonna pop off
so we're just getting ready to throw it
down in the middle of a restaurant and
then they'll like come up sometimes
it'll be a table full of gangsters yeah
like tattooed up they're all whispering
they're like it looks like they're
plotting yeah but they were just egging
each other on to like have somebody go
up to us and ask us if we're the the
youtube guys yeah and they're like oh
[ __ ] they come up like they're like hey
are you those youtube guys or whatever
and then my heart's like pumping like
[ __ ] man and then oh [ __ ] yeah and then
when we said yeah they start get like
the fangirl comes out they're like oh my
god [ __ ] it you're the guy like it's him
and then all their [ __ ] thug buddies
start giggling and coming over and [ __ ]
it's like a different side of human
beings man but that really helped
like see us see people differently
like not everyone's you know gonna fight
you or whatever or stab you yeah i
thought everything was like a fight
waiting to happen everywhere
you still feel that way uh way better
now but when i go to clubs i still feel
weird i remember we went to like a
youtube i don't like clubs you're also
an introvert so that would be weird too
yeah yeah dude imagine bart at a club
dude
yeah we went to a club that one time
what was that like i don't know you guys
lost you guys really quickly feel like
you guys drifted off if i found a
mattress on my earlier yeah i've never
seen partner club he's got a bloody nose
right now
i would love to see bart in the club we
went to the club in australia yeah and i
just saw geo push the [ __ ] out of that
dude down on the floor oh yeah did you
push some dude did i not mention this no
dude okay first of all it's most this is
my first time meeting geo and bar and
joe
and casey in australia and then [ __ ]
it's just one of those nights where
everybody's getting out and going social
and there's this [ __ ] club we're on
tour so like after the tour would go and
hang out oh [ __ ] and then everybody's
just standing in a circle because you
know there's a
[ __ ] ton of like fans inside so it even
as like a bunch of like social
influencers and youtubers like first we
just get there we start chilling but
people are being weird always you know
and this one guy comes up like while
we're all just standing in a circle and
just starts being really weird with his
dancing and just gets up onto geo
and at first i'm like i have no idea
what geo is like by any means right i
honestly i'm like oh it's bart and joe
who are doing like the the actual shows
and jio's kind of just there i'm like
cool maybe she's just their admin
assistant or whatever right guy starts
dancing on her and she [ __ ] turns up
and she pushes
so hard i swear it's like 10 feet this
little flies and like rolls
[ __ ] like rolls right and i'm like oh
[ __ ] like a [ __ ] putty and power
ranger
he disintegrates
all right i'm going to be her friend
make sure she's she's on my safe side
you're always kind of scary as [ __ ] that
was the same club that i got kissed up
by an indian dude oh yeah they give him
a deep kiss on his cheek what is this
yeah
yeah
yeah
where was he where what was it
that's why he doesn't like going to
clubs bro
he has weird trauma about chloe it was a
blur bro i think it was brisbane though
but see you just told us the story is if
we all heard it before i never heard
that story i think he's told us so this
guy i don't know anything about the
story we're just having a good time
letting loose because you know we're
only going to spend a day or two in
every city we're going to be in so we go
to the club and i'm there and it's
usually kind of like a safe space it's
like the promoters and the promoters
friends
and somehow i don't know people
stragglers will make it into our group
somehow uh but my guards are down so
we're just having a good time dancing
around whatever and then this guy comes
up to me and he tells me that he's a fan
oh that's dope dude and then he's like
can i have a hug on my shirt and then we
we embrace
and then he kisses me on my ear oh
that's weird i was like what the [ __ ]
keeps me on the lips full not here
i looked at it and i was like
[ __ ] this is so weird i don't even know
what to do
you said that i don't know i was
thinking about it
every funny people said that hey don't
do that
well i don't know because i'm like never
got kissed in a year
that's wild bro but then like but then
if i yell at him i'm also yelling on a
fan i feel bad and then i'm like
if i punch him then that's like
assaulting assaulting yelling and you're
like what if i punch him i'm just like
they're not then i'm punching a fan
you're spitballing you're spitballing
i'm just like listening i'm just listing
out all the options
and i i think i just the option i chose
was i'm just going to stay in place
frozen place
you basically
went through sexual harassment he just
froze and then he froze and as soon as
he left i couldn't wait to tell joe and
jill that fights got kissed by a dude
you guys are famous man i was like that
was crazy dude all that military
training and you froze but you don't get
trained for that kind of stuff maybe
they should they don't train you [ __ ]
like you're [ __ ] in the battlefield
some guy comes up to you and kisses you
and [ __ ] they need to up the training
yeah i mean [ __ ] kissing on the cheek
i'd probably be like oh he's italian but
kissing on the ear is so different yeah
didn't you say recently the military
gone soft maybe they are doing kissing
training though now they are yeah they
probably are now just on the ear though
start slow what was the actual question
like
how are your friends still and not hate
each other
why are you guys still friends why are
you guys still friends everybody else
balanced
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you